let's sort out all these developments
with Ben Goldberg er assistant managing
editor at Time magazine Ben good morning
morning let's start with the McCabe
firing and I want to point out that in a
phone interview with CBS News McCabe
said I strongly believe this is the
latest chapter in a year-long attack on
my credibility and service to the
country what are the political
ramifications of this we don't yet know
the extent of them but the firing itself
certainly the timing of the firing
McCabe's response to it and also the
president's response to it last night
ensure that the scrutiny on the special
counsels investigation is only going to
intensify the president seems to be
pursuing a go-it-alone approach on
hiring and firing so what what is that
what are the implications for Robert
Muller and his probe I think we don't
know directly what this is going to mean
for the probe itself it's not clear if
the firing of McCabe is going to have a
material effect but McCabe was very
clear in no uncertain terms in both his
statement and then in multiple
interviews with CBS and with other
reporters that he believes this was an
attempt to sideline him in part because
he could corroborate James commis
testimony about Muller's investigation
and potential obstruction you think it
suggests that the president is open to
firing robert muller does it suggest
that certainly but we've always known
that he's potentially opening you open
to it I mean trying to get inside this
president's head is something of a
fool's errand let's look at the the
shake-up we've had in the White House at
which which appears it may continue in
the coming week what's going on here do
you think in some ways the president is
starting to settle into the job that
this is the way he has run the Trump
Organization he is the only present
we've ever had without any military or
political experience his only frame of
reference is a private business that he
oversaw in which the only constant was
his position at the top and everybody
else sort of hovered around him it's
starting to resemble that a little bit
more it is easy to forget that earlier
this week the president fired Rex
Tillerson Mike Pompeo is likely to take
his place one of the implications in
terms of foreign policy given how many
things the administration is juggling on
that front indeed although I don't think
we should take it as a complete given
that Pompey will be confirmed by the
Senate which does need to happen
although I think it's very likely but he
is far more hawkish
than his predecessor Rex Tillerson
certainly on the Iran deal which he has
been very outspoken about and in that
way is consistent with the president he
would like to nullify it or essentially
weaken it to irrelevance and also most
pressingly with North Korea in which he
has even floated the notion of
pre-emptive war does this delay the
potential summit with Kim jong-un I
think there's no doubt that it
complicates it but the president's aides
were walking back and logistics about
that almost as soon as he announced it
although the president has said he wants
that meeting to happen by the end of May
and and he said that recently and the
one thing we know about this president
if he says he wants something to happen
it may take a while but eventually he
will get fed up with anyone standing in
his way of that can we talk a little bit
about the special election in
Pennsylvania and what that portends for
2018 both for Democrats and for
Republicans I think it certainly bodes
well for Democrats and Republicans
should be somewhat scared about it
although we shouldn't read too much
nationally into the race Paul Ryan in
the immediate wake of it tried to
downplay it he said that Connor Lam was
essentially a Republican he laid up many
of the conservative trappings privately
however he was telling his aides to
alert the rest of the caucus that this
is a wake up call
they needed to start fundraising
immediately they needed to hire staff
that there are a lot of members who
weren't ready for November and they
needed to see this as a four-alarm fire
this also exposed some fissures within
the Democratic Party to because there
were some Democrats who are complaining
that Connor Lam wasn't democratic enough
well that's exactly right and I think
that one of the reasons that Connor Lam
was able to sort of win as easily as he
did is that there wasn't a primary and
that that won't be the case for a lot of
other candidates Connor Lam was
essentially able to run just as he was
without facing something but ideological
purity test from his left mm-hmm big
existential questions for each party Ben
Goldberger with time thanks for thanks
for your time